[Music]
oh [__]
Wednesday afternoon you bad [__]
I don't want to live no more get ready
[__]
[Music]
how one live no more what the front door
I got the day another struggle I don't
want to live no more oh [__]
oh [__]
biggie 95 the beginning of it all
[__] oh [__] I don't want to live
no more what watch that [__] shine your
shoes uncle Joey's here [__]
[__] Eyewitness News or jeopardy or
World News Tonight all they gonna do two
years lie Obama didn't put the wiretap
in there go [__] yourself
I could put a wiretap in your house well
we didn't have an order are you [__]
my how the Americans really have [__]
[__] they've been tapping me for
years but I don't give a [__] jack uncle
Joey here pre Church swinging dick and
giving our [__] bazooka bubble gum
cuz that's how we do it my trusted
friend is here Lisa at the Goomba death
aka anti Lent because we're [__]
throwing down so I gave up edibles for
Lent
I had to do it to lower the resistance
get my head together get my thoughts
together
I switched up the [__] pills and
acupuncture [__] just joking just
joking just joking next thing you know
the DA's coming here shaking me down or
they're gonna get us a box ice cubes
[__] damn
you
nobody kicks like the Mueller set you
understand me I might raffle this off
and donate the rest to a cat [__]
charity we're gonna start this 1500 is
the mule of that [__] this is
busted up more lungs and [__] we got
everybody team down ray
Danny [__] Jackson we got everybody
this my Michael Jackson Janet Jackson
Jackson Jackson we ain't [__] around
no more bond history Jerry's kids you
know all day all night 24/7 I don't need
no [__] show the smoke Reef I don't
need none it's you and me against the
[__] world I'm with you you're with
me and they wanna be with us you
understand me [__] that I don't want to
live no more oh oh [__] you bad
[__] this is the jam oh [__]
the Junior MAFIA
oh [__]
[Music]
what are you gonna do now what are you
doing your life listen to this thing
right here and you wanna be a [__]
racist [__] or whatever the [__] you are
these black people are [__] savages
understand me then my [__] life
that's why I tell people to stay black
listen for this [__]
twenty something years old understand
[Music]
that sty the projects and here you are
crying you [__] button listen to this
[__] see notes by the layers true
[__] players what by the [__] tree
[Music]
oh [__] that day put this [__] album
on something straight out of a black
[__] tenement
what do you got you're livin around
complaining about Trump and Hillary you
think when he was writing this he was
concerned he was concerned about [__]
eat the cheese sandwich are you [__]
nuts
[Music]
Oh check it out biggie smalls Junior
MAFIA
[Music]
first time I heard the next song coming
up I thought I was gonna jump out of a
[__] window it's the song in Copland
when he's on the bridge crossing the
bridge and the guy pulls up and shoots
at him with a [__] Uzi oh [__] here
we go [__]
Oh get get that briefing ready
[Music]
live this [__]
what this is call mercy back for you
[__] to sit there on your
little computer typewriters and call
people names e [__] anonymous names this
is for you [__] oh [__] we're
gonna switch back to this [__] oh [__]
[Music]
guys break it that [__] number is as
good as it gets in the [__] rap world
what what now their teeth looking jump
oh [__] [__] the football team hitting
Oh
[Music]
I check myself before I wreck myself
disrespect myself oh [__] what I wanna
be it what put this [__] owl mine you
wanna baby maybe when he wrote this and
you're complaining and you complaining
he's riding the deck he worms to read
them right now and yeah I'm gonna do
about the illegal immigrant bad nothing
you'll wipe mine your physic oh [__] oh
[__] here we go move those shoulders
[__] gonna come up with me you're
[__] hot you dirty [__] what
what what what muscle muscle up on the
tack
oh [__] here you go [__] get on
your knees and give like God's love tell
him to put you on this planet meanwhile
this guy's rotting the deadly you're
having a headache go [__] yourself
I'm dropping like you [__] what
what what
oh [__]
oh [__] were busting in here tonight
[__]
what what what get your [__] together
write your goals smoke that reefer and
at the end of the day tell them all to
suck your dick is you're the captain
Tucker your enterprise [__]
what oh [__] oh [__] everybody feel I
read oh [__]
alright youtube.com slash c / joey beers
give me about 10-15 minutes you want to
continue this [__] party and then you
are sitting there roaming in the food
allowance drop oh are you kidding me a
wife I'll see you [__] in 15
minutes the Churchill what's happening
now coming at you my man Chris Harrison
thirty thirties calm in supposedly and
we got a guess that we will have this
party [__] rocking tonight look at me
I'm sweating just talking to you [__]
I'm giving everything I got here don't
forget the purchases out stay black